house come race running food and welcome
back
I said back because Willard play this
remember you don't that's ok
let's light turbo dispatch it's a really
funny game and it just came out on Steam
so I'm excited to see what else they got
this time around customization so I can
select my own face oh that's awesome
wow that's awesome hahahaha alright
let's start with the original classic
one house it's a key oh my
huh you look so beautiful so the point
of this game is to make as much damage
to poor ol Bob here alright howdy ha ha
ha his face it's perfect
oh god man you're into kinky stuff Bob
aren't you one of the obstacles gonna be
that's perfect
maximum speed ha you can do it just hang
on I told you oh [ __ ] the vehicle breaks
out BAM
alright we play that one already so
let's do another one chicken that sounds
pretty good
what the hell is this oh [ __ ]
Bob I think you're in trouble Oh kinky
nice ass Bob I don't know if I have a
complimented you on that
I like big oh that's great this is
literally Yolo no come on man
hang on you [ __ ] you don't let go yo
you goddamn [ __ ] believed in Yolo Bob
that's the only Oh what the [ __ ] are you
doing that's a really weird position man
holy [ __ ] are you okay though how was
the ride sasquatch damn
oh this is awesome what the ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha are you sure you want to do
this mom oh god I love this game what
the [ __ ]
oh good puncture wound I've gotta burn
the ass oh that burns yes that better
see a tree okay
he's full of shame he doesn't even want
to look at me Oh what oh it's awesome
Bob what do you feel about that Oh God
trust me I'm this will be fine this is a
great idea
hang on you but scared me oh my god all
right let's do it again maybe not the
best idea in the world but hey probably
not the worst one either
oh god damn what are you doing Bob I
would get out of the way if I were you
well this your clothes uh uh hey guy
you're fine
see it's fine you got your brother's
worry too much about Bob don't worry Bob
just stay right out up up up ha ha ha
aiming high oh okay go for it Bob
the sky's the limit Bob just remember I
love you
and nothing means more than love oh nice
front-flip uh-huh this whole long bob
you'll be fine I think
ow Oh God oh that's an excellent damage
man yeah
you're quite the daredevil Bob I'm proud
of you you're like a Tom Cruise badass
or not Bob is just having a nice day
looking out the window and it just got a
whole lot of worse oh shut up Bob first
he must ride this truck then you have my
permission to die Bob look at me look at
me Bob it's important that we trust each
other there you go see you love me too
don't you oops forgot to tell him about
the wall that's a nice car you got there
Bob thanks Pat I like the color me check
oh [ __ ] space program then we do this
one yeah we did but now we have better
cars pink lightning to space go to space
close enough oh god no oh no he's
[ __ ] me that's what you get Tom Amy
Bob oh damn
that's pretty awesome oh not so awesome
wrong direction Bob that is not space
I'm pretty sure that's the wrong better
ouch
hi I told you I was like fifty fifty
percent sure how are you today bad are
you enjoying the weather
you relax aren't you Bob that's great I
love you too Bob you might want to watch
out Bob
oh it's gonna be good for you Bob with
an ass like that you're gonna go far in
life and deaf for that matter trust me
Bob it's way safer to sit outside the
car trust me I know that whoops
maybe not skid marks this should be good
what the [ __ ] is this Bob is a little
nervous it's like nope it's late I don't
wanna shut up Chuck Oh goddamn F which
one have we not used yet I want the
kinkiest put oh god hahahaha that it
that is very sexy Bob very kinky I love
it I can tell you Bob you have a great
ass you're gonna do great in Hollywood
what's the point of this it's a race
Bobby in it you need to step it up
what's going on it what's happening Oh
Oh that split though I can't believe you
lost you're a disgrace there we go
come on that's maxed like that physio
car aah
the g-force hahaha oh [ __ ]
notice me senpai why do you have to be
so kinky Bob there are kids watching Bob
believe in yourself Bob I'm sure you can
do it oh look what a mess you did Bob
you're disgrace
whatever you do Bob don't let go what
did I say now you have to pay the price
Bob I'm sorry oh no oh no oh
still talking Mel you don't have to eat
broccoli if you don't want to be the
Yolo you are sexy Bob that side nice
front flip nice front left see he
actually made it holy [ __ ] okay
nice jump oh you might want to move uh
Bob
nevermind for the bros yeah oh he's
getting smashed oh no did I hear someone
say bro hey what up [ __ ]
limbo Bom can you do it can you do it oh
well god damn it
you suck beards no pets what did I ever
do to you bing-bong that's what you did
you piece of [ __ ] I'm actually quite
comfortable
oh god dear me do you trust me Bob do
you trust me with like are you shittin
first mistake never trust oh it is where
is his head what Duff awk
oh no I don't know it's awesome
hi Pat's hide hide I think you had
enough damage for today so let's just
ride nicely two boys the same stitch
thank you pants I appreciate it oh you
shut up my [ __ ] it ain't over till I
say it is over [ __ ]
I press that's all the time had for
today hope you enjoyed watching some
turbo dismount it's a really funny game
it's in early access on Steam so that
means it's gonna get updated so if you
want me to play more leave a like and
let me know I really appreciate it hit
subscribe I come over today I'll see you
bros in the next one as always stay
awesome bros love you
oh god no oh no he's [ __ ] mad